so there's a fight in Congress going on
right now over funding the government
Republicans are holding Dhaka hostage
until the Democrats agree to pay for
Trump's big beautiful wall it's a real
Deal or No Deal situation which is not
good The Apprentice was a way better
show but if the stingy Flemish rats
won't fund it how are we going to
finance the wall Oh Jordan it doesn't
matter
Kobe lebih everybody explain yourself
Jordan we don't need to worry ourselves
over funding an actual physical wall
because the wall is a metaphor I didn't
see that pose decided Jordan a metaphor
is a symbol and this symbol is very
clear it says immigrants are yes and you
can't quote me on that in your me and
think pieces because it's just a noise
so it doesn't matter who funds the
actual wall because this metaphorical
wall has already been built okay Kobe
look I don't care about your literary
devices we need something solid to keep
the immigrants out actually we don't
most illegal immigrants are here because
they overstayed their visas and the ones
who cross usually do so at a border
crossing a big concrete slab won't help
with any of that but a metaphorical wall
will a wrong nothing is stronger than
bricks a lesson I learn every week in
karate class but Jordan the metaphor is
already a huge success at keeping people
out we've created an environment of
animosity and unwelcome nests and we add
another brick to our metaphorical wall
every time we talk about building a
physical wall it gets higher every time
our president calls other nations
shitholes and every time there's a story
about Border Patrol agents destroying
water supplies left for migrants so that
they're stranded in the desert and
forced to migrate somewhere else heaven
whoa that that's that's a metaphor right
no they really have done that but more
importantly the culture that inspired
these guards to deprive people of
life-giving water is what's really
working under Trump there's been a 24
percent drop in people caught illegally
crossing the US border they're not even
trying to come now hey Kobe look I I
still want a real wall the biggest most
beautiful wall that Trump promised me
well Jordan people can always get around
a physical wall no Trump's wall no nut
is no one could get past that Jordan
think about it isn't there any way
around it okay I guess you could maybe
build a really deep tunnel and well I
guess you could pull bolt over it or
dress up like a sexy lady and hide a
ladder under your skirt seduce the
border guard and while he's falling in
love with you climb over oh yeah yeah
you could uh you get three guys stand on
each other's shoulders the guy on top
jumps over grabs the other guy's hand
swings him over the third guy the ground
probably doesn't get to go you can tie a
bunch of balloons around your waist you
could get jetpacks or ramps I forgot
about ramp ramp Lauren Jordan it's fine
it's okay if Mexicans know about ramps
because America's true wall is up here
and there's no ramp that can get over
here huh
thank goodness Kobi Libby everyone
[Music]